We're going to have hotter,
drier summers in our cities.
We're going to have to deal
with more frequent and intense heat waves.
It's going to have an impact
on our health and well-being,
but not just us.
What about the plants and animals
that call our cities home?
So what could we do about that?
We could green our cities,
we could plant trees.
The shade provided by trees
provides protection
from those impacts of the heat.
But what do we need to make
those plants thrive and survive?
We need water.
Our green cities need water,
but mosquitoes also like water.
And so how can we balance the impacts
that come from both of those,
if we perhaps are inadvertently
creating increasing pests
and public health risks for ourselves
in the ways in which we try to respond
to a changing climate?
How can we green our cities
and not create a problem with mosquitoes?
The mosquito is the deadliest
animal on the planet.
About half a million people die every year
because of mosquito bite.
Diseases such as malaria and dengue
infect hundreds of millions
of people every year, across the planet.
That burden of disease
weighs quite heavily
on both communities and local authorities,
as they struggle to try to deal
with those impacts.
Here in Australia,
we're very fortunate to be free
of some of the more serious
mosquito-borne diseases,
but there are still pathogens
spread by local mosquitoes
that can make us sick.
So something like Ross River virus.
If we get infected with this virus,
we may not die,
but we could get seriously ill.
Fever, rash, joint pain, fatigue ...
We could be battling illness
for many months.
But notwithstanding the burden of disease,
what about the nuisance that mosquitoes
can have just to our day-to-day lives?
How many of you have been
bothered by mosquitoes
when you're outside, enjoying the barbecue
or visiting the local wetlands
during summer?
What about that mosquito
that buzzes around your bedroom at night?
How can we manage these risks
and move forward,
and try to live in a greener city
and not create opportunities
for mosquitoes?
So I spend my summers
sloshing about in wetlands,
wrangling mosquitoes.
Despite the sunburn
and the mosquito bites and the mud,
I actually do quite like my job.
And I've also got a confession
to make to you all ...
I actually quite like mosquitoes.
(Laughter)
I'm quite fascinated by them.
I think they're actually quite beautiful,
if you get a chance to look at them
underneath the microscope.
So before I started my research
and first looked through
a microscope at a mosquito,
I don't think I'd really given them
much of a thought.
I knew that they were involved
in outbreaks of disease overseas,
and I was quite familiar with that smell
of a smoldering mosquito coil.
It still reminds me of summer holidays.
But the work I do now,
together with that of scientists
around the country,
is trying to work out how we can
stop people getting sick
because of mosquito bites.
It requires us to understand
the role that mosquitoes have
in our local environment,
and how we can change our cities
so that we're greening our cities,
we're mitigating those impacts
of climate change,
but at the same time not creating
opportunities for mosquitoes.
Did you know there are over 60
different types of mosquitoes
that are found in Western Sydney?
So it's not just that one mosquito
that you slap on your arm and squash;
they're an incredibly diverse
and interesting range of animals.
There's 60 different types
across Western Sydney.
These mosquitoes might be big,
they might be small.
They might be black
with distinctively striped legs.
They might be a pale brown color.
Or they might be
a really vibrant orange color.
But one of the things I love
about all of these mosquitoes
is that they're very unique,
they've adapted to very different
types of environment.
It’s one of the reasons that I like them,
because they’re incredibly adaptive.
But it’s also the thing
that worries me about them,
because they could be adapting
to these sources of water
we're creating around our cities.
So mosquitoes are found in an incredibly
wide range of environments,
from coastal rock pools
to snowmelt streams in our Alpine regions,
from polluted drains to pristine wetlands
and almost every puddle
of water in between.
There are mosquitoes found
in all of these environments.
And understanding how the mosquitoes
interact with these environments
and the climate
is really important to understand
how they might play a role
in outbreaks of disease.
But all of these mosquitoes
essentially need two things:
they need blood and they need water.
So I'll get to the blood
in a little while,
but let me talk to you about why water
is really important for mosquitoes.
The humble mossie is a really frail
and fragile creature.
Looks like it'll fall apart
in a strong breeze.
It's hard to imagine these are the most
dangerous animals on the planet.
But these animals kind of rely on water;
they've got an amazing life cycle
that starts in the water.
They need water.
So eggs are laid in and around
sources of water,
and then, when it rains,
or tides come into the wetlands,
these eggs hatch, and out of these eggs
hatch these wormlike larvae
that swim around in the water.
Maybe you’ve seen them in puddles
or your pot plant saucers.
Or maybe, as I did as a child,
if you're a bit slow to clean
your backyard swimming pool
when warmer weather arrives,
all of a sudden,
you can see these mosquitoes
swimming around at the top of the water.
But during summer,
it might only take a week or so
for them to emerge from that water
and start flying around.
They only live for a few weeks,
but during that time,
they can bite a lot of people,
and they can lay
more than a thousand eggs.
But to get those eggs, they need blood.
Mosquitoes need blood,
that's why they bite.
It's only the female mosquito that bites,
and she needs that protein hit
in her blood to develop her eggs.
They can live quite happily on plant
juices and sugars, most of the time,
but they really need
that blood to develop eggs.
And the animals they can get
that blood from can be incredibly varied,
from cows and kangaroos
to birds to frogs.
But also us.
And I know some of us in this room,
you're probably thinking,
"Boy, mosquitoes sure like to bite me
more than they like to bite my friends."
And sometimes, we can be
a bit unlucky like that.
But it's also important to remember
that mosquitoes, when they bite,
can not only create
an itchy red lump on our skin,
but they can also make us sick.
They can transmit pathogens
that make us sick.
But mosquitoes aren’t flying around,
transferring droplets of infected blood
from person to person.
These are not dirty syringes;
they’re much more complicated organisms.
So the mosquitoes themselves
have to become infected with the pathogen
before they can pass that on to us.
And when it comes
to pathogen transmission,
not all mosquitoes are created equal.
It's why it's really important
to understand mosquitoes,
because even though we have dozens
of mosquitoes here in Sydney
that could transmit
something like Ross River virus,
there are no mosquitoes
currently in Sydney
that can transmit the pathogens
that cause more serious diseases,
things like dengue, chikungunya or Zika.
Let's hope it stays that way.
So what does a green city
look like for a mosquito?
So first of all, there are trees
that provide shade,
protection from wind and sun ...
It provides these kind of protected,
humid little areas,
where mosquitoes can take refuge.
The longer mosquitoes live,
the more people they bite,
the more eggs they lay.
But it’s not so much the plants
but the water they need,
which is really critical for mosquitoes.
So in a green city, we have water tanks,
we build wetlands.
We’ve got green walls and frog ponds.
We’ve got bioretention basins.
We’ve got rain gardens.
All of these structures that might be
designed to store and recycle water
in and around our cities and suburbs
could be used by mosquitoes.
Remember, mosquitoes love this water
that's available to them.
So how can we design our cities
so that mosquitoes aren't quick to adapt
to these types of environments?
Wherever there's water,
mosquitoes will lay eggs,
and we have to be mindful about that
as we try to respond and green our cities,
create the structures that will help us.
It'll make a city greater.
I want to live in a green city.
I would love to live in a green city;
it's probably great for my physical
and mental health and well-being.
I just don't want to share that
with too many mosquitoes.
And mosquitoes are so adaptive
that I'm sure that they're going
to create opportunities
in these structures that we're building,
and so I'm really worried
that we're going to see
more and more mosquitoes into the future.
So how do you create a wetland
that's not home to mosquitoes?
One of the really interesting pieces
of research we've found in recent years
is that problematic mosquito populations
often seem to be associated
with wetlands of poor health:
wetlands that have more stagnant water,
wetlands that don't have enough predators
to eat the mosquitoes.
So it’s a tantalizing idea
that if you can create
a wetland that's healthier,
it has more water flow,
it has a greater level of biodiversity,
you can actually keep
mosquito populations down.
If you provide habitats
for the animals that eat mosquitoes --
the birds, the bats,
the fish, the frogs, the spiders,
any number of aquatic insects
that love munching on mosquitoes --
rather than being a problem,
mosquitoes are not going to disappear,
we're not going to get rid
of mosquitoes completely,
but if they're at a more balanced
place in the ecosystem,
maybe we'll have fewer pest impacts,
and more importantly,
maybe we will see less
mosquito-borne disease.
But what about stormwater drains?
These are already a common sight
in our local wetlands,
and there's a mosquito
that calls these habitats home,
which you all already know.
You may not notice it
when it flies past you,
but you know its sound.
You've probably learned to hate
the sound of this mosquito,
more so than its bite.
This is a mosquito called
the brown house mosquito.
It loves breeding in polluted ponds
and pipes and waterways;
it's going to be quick to exploit
the ways in which we store
wastewater in our cities.
The thing is about this mosquito
is that it loves coming indoors at night.
It's the mosquito that's going to be
buzzing around your face at night,
keep you awake, disrupting your sleep.
Now the reason you can hear that mosquito
is not because it makes a sound
that's different to any other mosquito.
It's just that a mosquito
prefers to bite birds,
and so it's flying
around your face and your body,
responding to your heat
and the smell of your skin, working out,
"Is this a large, featherless bird?
I'm not sure whether
I want to bite it or not."
It's bad luck for those of you
who smell a bit like a bird.
(Laughter)
But it's a reminder that sometimes,
it's not just the bite of mosquitoes
that's the problem,
it's the disturbance that can be caused
by large numbers of mosquitoes.
And so we don't want these mosquitoes
coming inside our homes,
where we're kind of creating opportunities
for these mosquitoes in our cities.
So what about our backyards?
We all want to keep our backyards healthy,
we want to have a great opportunity
for our plants and our pets
and the local wildlife.
One effective way to do that
is installing a rainwater tank.
Problem is, rainwater tanks
can be a great source
for very serious mosquitoes.
You all in this room
have probably been bitten
by the Australian backyard mosquito.
Its scientific name is Aedes notoscriptus.
It is the most widespread
mosquito in Australia;
almost everybody has opportunities
for this mosquito in their backyard.
Whether it's a birdbath,
a pot plant saucer,
even the smallest volumes of water
trapped in a water-holding container
will be a place this mosquito
can lay its eggs.
It's a nuisance biting pest,
but it's not a serious threat
to our health.
But there's a problem here,
because these same habitats
where this mosquito is found
could also be the home of a mosquito
that's associated with the transmission
of much more serious pathogens,
pathogens that can cause
outbreaks of disease
such as dengue, chikungunya and Zika.
These mosquitoes
are the Asian tiger mosquito
or the yellow fever mosquito.
These two mosquitoes are not found
in Sydney at the moment,
but worldwide, they contribute to major
outbreaks of mosquito-borne disease.
They don't breed in wetlands,
they love these water-holding
containers in our backyards.
And as we do a better job
of creating these opportunities
like rainwater tanks in our backyards,
maybe we're creating an opportunity
for these mosquitoes to move in.
The yellow fever mosquito, Aedes aegypti,
was actually once common in Sydney,
but during the '50s, it disappeared.
One of the reasons for its disappearance
could well have been the fact
that we moved away from rainwater tanks.
And now, rainwater tanks are coming back.
They're going to become more common.
And could that see the return
of these mosquitoes?
I certainly hope not.
So what can authorities do
about reducing the mosquitoes
associated with these greening cities
that we're dealing with?
There's a role for our local authorities
to consider mosquitoes
when they're building wetlands,
creating wastewater recycling schemes,
regulating the installation
of rainwater tanks.
Because these are dynamic systems.
It's not just about
how you design them and build them,
but it's how you maintain them.
You can't just build them and walk away,
because as we've learned,
if these habitats degrade,
they become more suitable for mosquitoes.
These types of structures,
these wetlands
in our cities, they're great.
They help reduce pollution,
they help store water,
but we don't want them to become
an opportunity for mosquitoes.
But what about us?
There's a role for local government,
for our local authorities,
but how an we help protect
our families and our friends
from the impact of mosquitoes
associated with a greening city?
I'm going to leave you with three tips
that can help you stop
the bite of mosquitoes
and the buzz of mosquitoes this summer.
First of all,
don't create opportunities
for mosquitoes in your backyard.
Anything that traps water after rainfall
will be a source of mosquitoes,
so tip out, cover up or remove
these water-holding containers
in your backyard.
Screen your rainwater tanks.
Clean your gutters and your drains,
reduce that standing water
that mosquitoes love so much
around our homes.
Secondly,
insect repellents are a safe
and effective way
to avoid mosquito bites.
When you're choosing a formulation
from the local pharmacy
or the supermarket,
make sure you apply it
as a nice, even coat
over all exposed areas of skin.
Don't put it on like perfume.
A dab here or there
is not going to provide protection.
Unless you've got complete cover,
those mosquitoes will find a way
to find that gap
in your repellent and bite.
Lastly, a way that you might be able
to stop the buzz of mosquitoes.
Why not just switching on a fan?
We know that operating a fan in a bedroom
can help reduce those mosquitoes
that come in and buzz around
our ears at night.
It disperses the smells
and the temperatures
around that body that attracts them;
it might make it a bit harder
for that mossie
to fly around and find us as well.
So finally, I want to leave you
with a thought.
We may hate mosquitoes, and I understand.
I don’t want to convert you
into loving these bloodsuckers.
But we need to understand them.
Because if we can’t understand
the diversity of mosquitoes
and their relationships
with the environments
we’re creating in our green cities,
it's going to become
a much greater struggle
to kind of reduce the burden of disease
that might come with them.
And unfortunately,
mosquitoes are going to be
yet another challenge we face
as we move forward into our future cities
under the impact of a changing climate.